When I was a kid, I looooved doing impressions
- I got a kick out of changing my accent and
prank calling my friends.
But, some people claim to be stuck with a
foreign accent.
Is this a thing?
Hello communicators, Lissette here for DNews.
A mother of two who lives in the UK seems
to confuse a lot of people.
If you saw her in a supermarket, you’d probably
guess she was a local, that is, until you
hear her speak.
Some people think she’s French, others German,
Italian, and yet others even Japanese!
She just doesn’t sound British.
People can’t seem to agree on what accent
she has, but they are certain she is speaking
in an accent.
The thing is, she’s never lived anywhere
but the UK, so what’s going on here?
Is she faking it?
Well, she told a Professor at the University
of Central Florida in Orlando, “I’m not
trying to be foreign.
I’m just trying to be me.”
Turns out, she’s telling the truth.
In March 2006 she began involuntarily slurring
her words and in the matter of days, her voice
had completely changed.
Doctors were baffled.
But, after numerous tests and observations,
she found out that she is one of the more
than 140 reported cases of people suffering
from a condition called Foreign Accent Syndrome
or FAS.
Foreign accent syndrome is a motor speech
disorder in which a person’s intonation
and stress patterns are altered.
The way they compose phrases and sentences
is also affected.
This causes them to be perceived as non-native
speakers of their mother tongue.
In the UK woman’s specific case, her funny
accent was a result of cerebral vasculitis
- basically this means that her brain was
not receiving enough oxygen in areas responsible
for language.
But, other types of brain injuries can cause
people to have Foreign Accent Syndrome too.
Another British woman woke up with a Chinese
sounding accent after having a severe migraine.
Yet others, have sounded differently since
birth.
A Dutch boy can’t help but speak in what
sounds like a French or Mediterranean accent.
Before him, all known cases of Foreign Accent
Syndrome were associated with brain damage,
so his case tells scientists there may also
be a genetic component involved.
This is why Dr. Johan Verhoeven from City
University London and his team decided to
investigate what was going on.
By using single emission CT scans, they found
that his brain had significantly less blood
flow to certain areas compared to other people.
They saw reduced flow to the prefrontal cortex
in the left hemisphere, which makes sense
because this area is associated with speech.
But, they also found that he had less blood
flow to the right side of his cerebellum.
This area is usually not associated with speech
- it’s thought to be more strongly linked
to body movement.
So this finding tells researchers that perhaps
the cerebellum is also involved with cognitive
functions - like producing speech.
People who develop these so called accents
are obviously not faking it.
It’s a real thing.
That being said, calling their condition Foreign
Accent Syndrome is a bit of misnomer that
may contribute to some people’s skepticism.
Nonetheless, for people with FAS, speaking
this way is not a matter of choice.
It’s just what it is - like a speech impediment.
One speech impediment that is a bit controversial
is the lisp.
Check out my episode on why some people have
lisps here.
Do you have a favorite accent?
Share your thoughts in the comments and remember
to subscribe so you never miss an episode
of DNews.
Thanks for watching.